the cia is not a bunch of shooters
running around picking locks and
climbing up the sides of buildings
but it didn't have enough people who
could operate in those types of
environments so it started poaching
from the military special ops community
that's how i got involved
what is the business model of human
trafficking that's attracting so many
people to want to go do it
profits this is strictly a money play
the misconception is that all
human traffickers are men and that is
not the case many human traffickers or
women
we had intelligence on a human
trafficker
that was moving children across a border
and they were specifically using those
children to test bombs
yet we have an entire government
bureaucracy that we spend billions of
dollars
fighting what is the illicit trade of
legal commodities
are these guys intimidated by that
they're like dude you're not gonna catch
me we know what we're doing we're
smarter than you they're thinking
they're gonna outsmart you every single
time
the reason that there are human
trafficking victims is because there are
human traffickers
so we don't need to spend all of our
time focusing on
on rescuing victims we need to focus on
preventing victims by getting
rid of human traffickers
my guest today may have one of the most
interesting stories
you've ever heard but i'm going to tell
you why i'm saying this because we've
had a lot of
interesting people on valuetainment so
number one he gets out of high school
while he's in high school he doesn't
want to attend high school because he
likes surfing so
he finds out how to hack into the high
school's attendance system
and shows that he showed up all year
long but he went surfing from there he
leads to going into the air force and
becomes a para rescue which para rescue
is comparable to
navy seal then he goes into the cia
cannot
tell you how long it is because i don't
know how long it is but it's several
years he goes into the cia
and then afterwards he decides to get
out to go fight human trafficking
and all along he gets a call from amazon
and vice saying we want to do a story
that's similar to your background
because everybody tells us what we're
about to write you're the closest thing
to this person
and that movie is jack ryan with that
being said my guest today is
nick mckinley nick how are you hey doing
well
doing well patrick thank you for having
me yeah it's good to have you man i mean
when i saw your story and
i said uh i can't find a lot of things
on this guy
and then they said well that's the idea
you know this the idea isn't to have a
lot of stuff on the life that he lived
you know sometimes you can't find a lot
of stuff on them
but uh going back to adults who
didn't have the abilities and the
intelligence that you had
can you tell us a little bit how did you
hack into the high school's attendance
system i think that's very critical info
for us adults here yeah so it was uh
you and i are uh about the same age i
believe you're you're about a year older
than me
and so right it's the 90s and uh
the computer systems weren't quite what
they what you would think they were
there's still a lot of like fill in the
bubble right put it in the machine
uh well it turns out that you're the
same pla you're you're the same
bubble and the same sheet every single
day
so if you just make sure that that
little sensor is covered up
when those sheets get fed in it shows
that you're there
uh and with that with the help of uh
help of a friend who worked in the
worked in the front office and it was
skiing not surfing actually
so i grew up in montana i grew up in
montana not not a lot of surfing in
montana
that makes sense yeah there's not the
beach dirt they don't have a fascinating
beach in montana i've not seen it at
least
no no lots of lots of rocks on some
really cold lakes
yes i have friends who live in montana
and they swear by it okay they swear by
how amazing montana is so
it's okay i mean uh your story obviously
it's
you know a lot of different uh lives
that you've lived and what you've done
but
so you get out of school you're going to
para rescue you have a lot of experience
there
take me from pararescue to wanting to
become a cia agent did they approach you
did you approach them was there somebody
that put an award for you
how did that whole process take place so
they actually called me
uh when you're when you're paralyzed by
the way is it common that they call you
i think that's relatively common uh
especially with the wars kicking off the
way that they were you know
contrary to what the the movies show
the cia is not is not a bunch of
shooters running around picking locks
and climbing up the sides of buildings
and don't get me wrong there are people
who do that
but the the kinetic side right so the
parts of the
the cia where you have to take a
physical fitness evaluation
and annual shooting evaluations you know
that is a
very very very small group of people
within what is a large
government agency and when
the cia found itself at war on multiple
continents
within dozens of countries it didn't
have enough people
who could operate in those types of
environments so it started poaching
from the military special ops community
and
that's uh that's how i got involved was
that pretty common like did you see
other friends that also got recruited or
no
oh it's very common very common i was i
was the first
i was the first person with a pararescue
background to become a staff officer
okay but as far as um what i like to
just call you know the guys on the team
which is where i started
that that was incredibly common most of
my teams
if not all of them were comprised of
military special operators who who were
now working
working for the cia okay and and when
you got recruited did you also say you
may want to call
johnny or bobby or larry because he may
also be good or is it more or less
you call them and recruit how does the
recruiting process work
so both i uh both directions right i
mean you don't want to
you don't want to set your buddy up for
some phone call from some random number
and him you know think it think it's a
spam call and miss the
miss a great opportunity so a number of
my friends i
i brought with me from the pararescue
teams and and
had them uh had them join me because
they were they were great operators and
great people to work with
pararescue cia which job did you like
more
oh that is a tough question
pararescue was a lot more sporty um
uh when when things when things went
wrong and you were getting called to
work as a pararescueman
uh it was it was sporty
um a lot a lot more jumping out of
planes and and
whatnot but the the thing about the cia
that i really liked
was there was very little training time
and that that can also be a bad thing
but there was very little training time
for the most part you were
operational constantly we were so
undermanned
uh you're spending 10 plus months a year
out of the country
bouncing around the most hostile
environments on the planet and
uh there wasn't there wasn't time to go
take three months
to go take a three-month training cycle
like you could in pararescue it was
it was constantly on the road how do you
how do you manage that and personal life
at the same time i mean it's it's
you know my buddy i talked to you about
you who was also special ops on what he
did
you know he said you know he was on his
third
marriage-wise you know that that he went
through he said it's very difficult to
hold it together when you're doing what
you do because you're on the road 10
months out of the year you don't know
where you're going to be at
how did you manage your personal life as
a cia agent or para rescue
uh so my first marriage uh ended in a
ball of flames uh i mean it was yeah
it wasn't good uh so so i could say that
i actually didn't
properly manage my my personal life
professional life
was on a rocket ship uh personal life
was an
absolute disaster and so
when i joined the agency they told me uh
you know they
said you know are you sure you want to
do this the unit you're going into has
an 86
divorce rate and of course the mindset
of of people like us is that oh well
that's the other folks that's not going
to be me
yeah right everything i've done to this
point in life i mean you know there was
an eight percent chance i was gonna
become a pararescueman
did it one percent chance i was gonna uh
get into the agency did it so oh 14
chance of making a marriage work i like
those odds
yeah that didn't work out well for me so
uh so you don't
and and then when i was i was dating my
now wife
um we we got married after i left the
agency
uh i went a six-month period where
she saw me for about three days in six
months like physically saw me for about
three days and six months and
and for the first majority of that i was
actually under a cover
so it wasn't until she came to me and
said
you know are you a drug dealer you know
what's going on because this just
doesn't make sense
and i'd already been authorized by the
agency to break cover and
and tell her you know where you know
where i was um
or not necessarily where i was but what
i was doing
well i got to tell you i mean please
don't take this as
uh personally but you know i'm about to
judge you a little bit if that's okay
with you
when i'm looking at you you look like
one of four professions okay you either
look like a drug dealer
you look like a hitman you look like a
cia agent or you look like ben affleck's
character from the movie accountant like
you look like you're somebody that you
shouldn't mess with your eyes
have a lot of fire in them like you're
calculating and studying every move of
the opponent you just look like that guy
so i i don't know if that's an edge or
not but you have a certain look about
yourself
that maybe was fitting for you to do
what you did as a cia agent
so funny uh that you say that because
the first time i did an undercover
operation i was going through a middle
eastern country
and i was flying civilian and they had
one of their intelligence agents just
sitting there watching people get off
the plane
and as soon as i got off the plane the
guy stood up
and walked up to me and said excuse me
sir would you follow me
and showed me a badge and and uh you
know what are you doing and i
you know fed in my story and he said
that's great
you have a 26 hour layover before your
next uh before your next flight
you can't leave the airport uh well
luckily the airport had a had a
starbucks which
had about the only padded chair in the
whole in the whole airport so i sat
there
uh while there were security guys just
out there smoking cigarettes watching me
uh and i didn't want to go to sleep that
didn't seem like that could go
that could go well for me so so yeah
that that look
doesn't really help you out all that
much but it's also really difficult to
get rid of
you know what's crazy while we're
talking about the guy that's the special
ops guy he's calling me right now you
know was the last time i talked to this
guy
a long time ago he's calling me right
now how random is this that he's calling
me right now
anyways i'm not gonna pick up because
it'll freak him out thinking like we're
up to something with him so i don't want
to
spook him even more uh but uh so
let's go through the process okay so you
got pear rescue
cia then human trafficking
so so make the connection between cia
to wanting to go like what event
happened what did you see
what bothered you what annoyed you what
inspired you say
this is what i want to do moving forward
how did that take place
it's not what i wanted to do moving
forward it's what it was my duty
to do this moving forward because this
isn't the human trafficking issue is
something that once you
really understand it and you understand
what's going on you can't
not do something right as william
wilberforce said you can't look
away and so it was a sequence of events
over a period of about
a little over seven years but it really
culminated i was in lashkar afghanistan
uh
working for various government
bureaucracies
and we had what i like to call smoking
gun intelligence
i was a staff officer working with a
jsof
jsoc counterpart joint special
operations command counterpart
and we had intelligence on a human
trafficker
that was moving children across a border
and they were specifically using those
children to test bombs
we had video of this so this became very
very
uh emotionally charged issue for us
children to test bombs yeah to test
bombs
what does that mean uh he was he was
building pressure plates
out of materials that you would find at
a junkyard i don't want to say exactly
what it was and how he was doing it
but he was building pressure plates and
he wanted to make sure that those
pressure plates
would would go off if a human stepped on
him but they he didn't want a
dog or a cat or somebody to you know
detonate his bomb
and so as he was testing these he was he
was using he was using young boys
uh and and would literally have them go
walk around
in a field where he had these pressure
plates buried
and once uh you know to to see to see if
they worked
and you personally witnessed this uh we
we had video of it yes
so we wrote up we wrote up the intel
uh we had uh uh we had somebody who was
telling us uh this stuff and
and we wrote it all up and sent it up to
sent it up the chain
and there was nobody nobody really cared
everybody thought oh this is very sad
but but
nobody really cared and that made me
curious
uh in a in a bad way almost right so
when you have that level of security
clearance right if you work
cia you have the highest security
clearance you can get
uh tssci with a full scope poly uh
and there's nothing that's off limits to
you so
i got on the computer system and started
looking for
that magic red door of competence that
was fighting human trafficking
and what i learned over a period of
years of you know digging around
classified systems and talking to
everybody i knew and
you know a bunch of special ops guys run
this experiment yourself
go ask them how many operations they've
ever done that involved going after a
human
trafficker and what you'll find is that
they'll tell you none
there's a bomb maker who maybe was also
selling kids on the side or a drug
dealer who
also was was moving people but but as
far as
going after somebody because they were
enslaving humans
i all i know were special ops guys and i
couldn't find a single one
who could tell me that they'd done an
operation against a human trafficker
and then fast forward a little bit
though why not though it's not a
presidential reporting requirement
so at the end of the day everybody who
works in the government is just a
soldier
who's doing what the the bureaucracy at
the top what the administration in
charge
says to do and and and let me ask you a
question
uh you're uh you're in texas correct
i'm in florida and i just moved here
three weeks ago but i have an office and
my headquarters is in dallas texas and
my headquarters is in dallas texas right
right on oakland and maple okay um so uh
so yeah so do we have a bureau of
alcohol tobacco and firearms
most people in texas in their office
have alcohol tobacco and firearms within
arm's reach
uh probably florida too uh yet we have
an entire
government bureaucracy that we spend
billions of dollars
fighting what is the illicit trade of
legal commodities
we have a drug enforcement agency 90 of
drugs are legal
more and more drugs are becoming legal
yet we have an entire government
bureaucracy that spends
tens of billions of dollars a year
fighting the illicit sale
of legal commodities the 13th amendment
makes
100 of slavery because that's what we're
talking about right human trafficking is
just a very very
very cushy word for slavery
100 of slavery is illegal yet
who's got the ball on that issue who
actually does though
who does have the ball on that so the
department of justice
uh great you know great agents doing
what they can
but there's not enough of them uh you've
got department of homeland security they
they try to do some work around human
trafficking but department homeland
security is very politicized
uh right now they've got handcuffs on
them on this issue
you've got state and local law
enforcement are really the ones that do
the major majority of the heavy lifting
we were just involved in the human
trafficking task force
at the super bowl multiple human
traffickers arrested multiple victims
free
the major majority of the agents we were
working with were
state and local right they were county
sheriff's deputies they were local
police
uh who who were doing this work yet
there's no intelligence
center that ties all these people
together that ties all these cases
together there's no
software platform that that becomes the
easy button
for fighting human trafficking right
because a law enforcement officer can't
go
put handcuffs on a bad guy and
start doing intelligence work on a
computer at the same time
so while i did was say well this is a
problem
distill it down to its foundational
principles which are primarily academic
right it's important that we remove the
emotion from this issue and look at it
for what it is
and said well this is a lot like
terrorism and fighting narcotics
overseas which
quite frankly the taxpayers should be
very proud of
the government and the people who are
fighting terrorism because
we're we're arguably the best in the
world at it
and if if the the process that we've
learned
over 20 years of war works for fighting
terrorism
then why won't it work for human
trafficking that's the thesis
and so in 2015 when i started deliver
funds specifically to
to go after that problem and take that
counter-terrorism methodology
and turn it into counter-human
trafficking and
it's been working
beyond uh our wildest imaginations of of
how how well it could have worked and
we're just getting warmed up i i want to
i want to come to your system
i'll come come back to the system of
what you guys do but
i saw an article here i almost didn't
believe it i said i want to ask
and nick and see what you're going to
say about it this is from a year and a
half
ago business insider wrote an article 20
staggering facts
about human trafficking in the u.s first
one was
human trafficking wasn't illegal meaning
it was legal until 2020
when the traffic and victims protection
act was passed which made it a federal
crime then president george w boy
signing the william
wilbur force trafficking victims
protection reauthorization act of 2008.
what does that mean human trafficking
wasn't illegal until 2000
well that that's a little bit of uh
of some click bait so so it's always
been illegal it's just been called
other things right jazz um
so uh uh it was usually prosecuted under
the man act
or pimping and pandering or what we what
we look at at these at these uh
as these uh kind of prostitution
commercial sex related
uh charges right should have a human
trafficking victim
who we have two human trafficking
victims who who work for us at deliver
fund
um and they'll tell you that every time
they got into contact with law
enforcement
they looked at them as prostitutes they
were being forced to do what they were
doing
and so all the trafficking victim
protection act did was
was put a wrapper on what was actually
happening
so it defined what human trafficking
was so it's not that human trafficking
was legal right it's still a crime to
force somebody to do something
it's just we didn't have it all packaged
up into one law
and so the trafficking victim protection
act said that
to distill down the language you are
guilty of human trafficking
if you are controlling somebody and
forcing them to work for your economic
benefit
or the economic benefit of somebody
other than themselves
and you're controlling them through
force fraud or coercion
and what we learned in doing this work
is that it's actually it always
starts with fraud rarely does this start
with force
or or coercion it usually
almost always starts with fraud
and then becomes force or coercion as
the method of control once
once they've defrauded the individual
what what does that mean once they've
defrauded the individual
what does that mean so let's take a case
of labor trafficking uh
you get uh you know young girl from
vietnam
uh answers an ad in uh
you know ho chi minh city for
nannies in the united states and she
thinks she's going to come over here
and and be a nanny for some wealthy
family and they interview her and make
her think all of this
and then they get her over here they
take her passport and they stick her in
an apartment brothel in new york
uh that's that's what i mean by fraud uh
you
we saw the same thing out of eastern
europe there were uh
nurses uh who were being recruited out
of eastern europe
and uh and and the balkans area as well
and they were bringing them over here
telling them they were going to be
nurses in the united states
took their passports stuck them in a
apartment brothel
uh and then you have even here in the
united states because major majority of
human trafficking victims
are are us citizens who are being
trafficked by u.s citizens and sold to
u.s citizens right there's a u.s
problem so you get a young girl at high
school
befriends the older guy that she meets
at the mall
he showers her with gifts gains her
trust
and then finally gets her to a party
drugs her you can use your imagination
from there and now she's
you know psychologically destroyed
and he's got control of her for life
so um i mean just thinking about it it's
uh
you know some movies do a good job
painting the picture of what happens
with this i think even recently one of
them was rambo i i never thought the
direction of the story would have gone
with rambo was about human trafficking
i don't know if you saw the movie around
oh you're not a movie guy just yeah i
didn't i didn't see it
the movie was about human trafficking on
what happened to his niece
with what sly had to do go out there and
try to save her but by then it was too
late because that drugged her way too
much that she couldn't make it
uh 150 billion your industry it's a
pretty big industry 150 billion out of
your industry
when i see stats different places 99
billion dollars 150 billion dollars
global
all these numbers what is the business
model
of human trafficking that's attracting
so many people to want to go do it
profits that's that's that's this is
this is strictly a money play for these
human traffickers um
it's a very low risk right now we've
been we've been increasing the risk but
it's very low risk
uh that you know if you're moving a kilo
of cocaine a drug dog can kick that
can can pick that up we have sensors
that can pick that up if you're moving
uh some scantily clad girls in the back
of a car and you're
maintaining the speed limits and your
brake lights are good
nobody knows that you're moving slaves
and so
i mean imagine if all of your employees
you didn't have to pay them
well what just happened to your profit
margins right and and so that's why
that's why they're doing this is it's
just sheer slavery
it's an uh predominantly there is forced
labor that happens in the united states
but the predominant business model is
commercial sex
but at the end of the day that's just
the type of labor that the human
trafficker
is selling and so some
some woman that and it's also it touches
um the lgbtq community it touches
touches all these vulnerable populations
they are exploiting these people these
human traffickers are exploiting these
people by making them
work and not paying them
and so their their their profit margins
are essentially
you know 80 90 95
what is the uh uh have you guys noticed
a pattern or a trend
of a human trafficker so somebody who is
doing it what is a typical pattern
are you noticing a consistency with a
pattern or is it just a criminal that's
all it is they just kind of want to make
money
any kind of patterns you guys have found
yes uh
so we we build our own software uh we we
have our own data collection
and we we have those patterns we
actually sit on top of the largest human
trafficking database in existence
largest and cleanest i've got over 70
law enforcement agencies around the
united states that are all
kind of working together on this
database and so what that what that
means
is we've been able to take this very
very clean data
and start analyzing it for patterns and
now we're getting to the point
where our software is actually just
going to be able to actually can bring
human trafficking to
our attention so we know exactly how
they work
and really their achilles heel you know
i talk about this on on other podcasts
and people say well nick how can you
talk about what you're doing don't you
need to be secret about it
nope i don't because if your business
model is that you need to be secretive
about something well that's not scalable
and that's that's not going to work
uh human traffickers have to advertise
if customers want to find you know a
date for the night so to speak right
that
usually the customers think it's
prostitution
and they they want to find that girl
they go to the internet
that's where this is all advertised
because if they put the girl on the
street
law enforcement can find it right law
enforcement has the right to go approach
her and talk to her
she might wrap the trafficker out so
it's a lot easier to keep her locked
into a
locked in a hotel room and advertise her
online
and there's there's dozens of websites
online i mean you could
you could get to these websites if you
know where you're going this is not in
the deep and dark web this is the
front-facing internet
the big famous one that everybody was
aware of that the doj took down
was backpage.com and so
you go to those you go to those websites
you schedule a date with a girl
there's a human trafficker who's
advertising that girl online
and and the transaction happens so
that's the achilles heel
of of the whole human trafficking market
in the
in the united states is that it's
predominantly online
and so if you're online that means
you're leaving a trail
and we're really good at treat at uh
chasing down those trails and seeing
where they lead so i just looked at
backpage.com founder michael lacy who
was michael lacy
uh he is currently uh under house arrest
um he was actually uh so the village
voice
which was a publication out of new york
right from the 70s i think
they had the back page when the back
page was
right it was a lot of your uh your
prostitution massage parlors
a lot of human trafficking and then they
took they took that back page
of the newspaper and took it online and
started selling one dollar
advertisements um to people who were
predominantly engaged in the commercial
sex industry
and uh everybody uh their their whole
c-suite was arrested they all pled
guilty uh
michael's including himself i know
michael lacy and
um i can't remember the other founder's
name off the top of my head
but they're fighting the charges because
they're old um
and you know they're they're going to
come out of prison in a pine box if uh
if they get convicted or should we say
when they get convicted so they are
how did how did the law enforcement find
out that backpage was doing this behind
closed doors
uh we we decided we the lever fund
decided to make backpage our hobby
uh oh so you did that you went after
back page because i see 2018 and you've
been around for six years so
we were uh we were one of many many
members of a of a team
uh the the the real credit goes to
federal law enforcement and uh
and actually uh texas ag's office they
did a phenomenal job
uh there's some law enforcement in
arizona that was working the case as
well
but when it came when it came to kind of
coordinating
a lot of the intelligence work and and
passing that off
uh we did uh we did a lion's share of
that for sure
so carl ferrer who was the ceo of
backpage i believe that's the name you
were trying to think about
did they know that human trafficking was
taking place and they kind of looked the
other way is that what the challenge was
yes they absolutely know that how did
they know that
because it's egregious uh i mean and any
any
any person who was looking at what was
happening
uh on their platform uh i mean they they
knew what was happening and the doj
actually has communications if you
research the back
back page case you'll find that's why
they pled guilty is because they were
literally talking about it on their
on their corporate communications uh so
they have the servers they
have everything that they were talking
about and they have them talking about
the fact that they knew this was
happening
um and they were they they were let me
give you
an example of the kind of thing that was
happening there there was a uh
a 12 year old girl who was advertised by
a human trafficker on backpage right so
you could tell
along with a photo um and he put her age
as 12 years old well backpage's
moderators
changed the age to 18 and then let
the ad go come on
absolutely evil i mean just just evil
so so i'm looking at alternative to back
pay so i'm assuming you target
craiglist.com
oilx facebook kg free ads
what are the websites you target that
can do exactly what backpage did uh
so i'm not going to give the names of
the uh websites that we
target actively uh these websites are
very profitable and i'm not interested
in uh i'm not even going to shut up okay
in that fight
um and and more importantly uh people
who don't know where to go telling them
where to go
uh but there's uh there's about 32 sites
right now
that are are the primary sites where the
source data comes from
uh and we we are actively
uh we're actively collecting from all of
those sites
so let me ask you this when you're
dealing with a company that
say they don't know that that is taking
place
and then they find out based on the
proof you show because
i think your model isn't you go attack
them your model is you go team up with a
70 or 60
law enforcement organization that you
work with you no longer kick the doors
down you
give the intel to those to go kick the
doors down i think if after doing some
research on your business model that's
your business model right
correct okay so so you find out
a company that's a real company they
have somebody who's a human trafficker
leveraging the
the the the clientele the traffic that's
coming to that website
do you then contact them and have the
business
work with you to get more that data for
you to pass down to law enforcement like
do the companies now help become a
teammate with you
that's always the first that's always
the first
place that we start so we have very
very publicly recognizable
partners publicly traded companies that
we work with to help them keep human
traffickers off of their platform
but a lot of these websites they
specifically moved
their business operations overseas into
non-friendly non-uh or non-friendly
non-extradition
u.s country uh countries so that they're
not
subject to u.s jurisdiction guidelines
that's kind of part of the problem
so how do you battle that right now
there's nothing we can really do
on that um we we have a way of diluting
their market
uh which we don't talk about publicly to
make it so that
it just complicates their business right
it just
it just makes it so that the the the
trafficker can never
quite get his product in front of the
customer and the customer can never
quite find a real product so we have
ways of of complicating that a little
bit
but primarily the way that the way that
we deal with that
is uh is by getting these human
traffickers arrested and that's that's
one
one key thing that we need to focus on
is
in order to have a human trafficking
victim which is the reason we're doing
this right
uh human traffickers are bad people
they're gonna do bad things
um there's nothing nick can do about
that however
they are they're exploiting people
they're harming
children and so the reason that there
are human trafficking victims
is because there are human traffickers
so we don't need to spend all of our
time focusing on on rescuing victims
we need to focus on preventing victims
by getting rid
of human traffickers makes sense
yeah that that makes sense and uh
so so sometime when you're you guys have
to wrestle with pigs quite often right
yourself like you you have to get dirty
yourself in order for you to be able to
uh make their life a living hell
i know i know you can't say yes or not
but your world is not like hey let's
take the proper route and you know let's
you have to make their life a living
kill by playing some of their games
against them no
so not so much playing their games
against them um
you know everything that we do is
reviewed by legal counsel
um we work with prosecutors love us uh
and we wouldn't be able to
we wouldn't be able to do the things
that we did if our if the
work that we put together was not
admissible in court
all right and and everything that we do
is admissible in court we're open to
discovery
it's uh it's a very very above
board operation but what we do is we
infiltrate their communications
uh and i hope there are human
traffickers out there right now
listening to that and wondering
whether or not that person they're
communicating with online is actually
one of my intelligence analysts
uh we infiltrate their communications
where they're they're
they're sharing best practices they're
um
they're they literally will will
coordinate with each other to say hey
you know the super bowl is coming to my
town
um i've only got three girls i need i
need other guys to come down and bring
more girls so that we can service what
is a market opportunity
for them and that's a a key
differentiator in the way that we fight
human trafficking is we fight it as a
market we fight it through economics
where in your business and in my other
business i'm always trying to
reduce risk right we're always trying to
mitigate it
what our whole what we do at deliver
fund is we
increase market risk for the human
traffickers to cut into their profit
margins and make it harder for them to
do business
yeah but human traffickers kind of like
obviously
you'll see where i'm going with this uh
uh nick only seven percent of people are
going to graduate
prairie rescue watch me do it only one
person is going to become a cia watch me
do it
86 which is only 14 of people that do
what you're doing right now
their marriage ends up at a divorce oh
if i beat seven percent and one percent
i'm going to beat 14
that's not a problem i got it right are
these guys intimidated by that they're
like dude you're not going to catch me
we know what we're doing we're smarter
than you they're thinking they're going
to outsmart you every single time
because no and and here's here's the
mystery you know what i'm saying right
you know what
no absolutely but here's a misconception
about human trafficking right people
will say that human trafficking is the
largest growing criminal enterprise it's
just not true
narcotics and guns especially with all
the wars going on around the world um
narcotics and guns are you know illegal
gun running as
is hands down the largest illicit
commodities uh
the next is uh people will say well you
can actually make
more money from uh you know from
selling human trafficking victims than
you can from narcotics or guns
that is also not true because you can
have a shipping container full of
cocaine or aks
sitting in a port somewhere and you can
leave it there for two years
and those the drugs and the guns are
worth just as much as they were
when you put that container there you
can't do that with people
right people have people require
overhead
you have to house them you have to feed
them you have to keep them in at least
good enough conditions so that customers
want to spend some time with them
uh and that's that's that's the achilles
heel that cuts
into the profit margins of of human
traffickers
and so most of your smart criminals i
mean your
your people who would be curing cancer
were they not criminals
um most of them are into some type of
organized crime
around either narcotics or guns or
you know ripping off banks credit card
fraud those types of things
it's actually uh in a there are
exceptions to this rule
but it's it's not your smartest
criminals who are human traffickers
there's also a piece here you know i saw
in doing research that you you've
interviewed many members of
of the mob my guess is if you go ask
them what they think about human
trafficking they're gonna say
that's over the line and if we found
somebody doing that in our organization
they were going to end up in a box and
that's what happens with a lot of these
these criminal enterprises too
is uh you know you'll have you'll have
uh
you know narcotics criminal enterprises
who aren't going to allow their people
to start harming children so so even
within the criminal
underworld there's there's an ethic line
when it comes to children
that people won't cross oh there's no
question about it
and they even had a code la cosa no sir
they wouldn't touch drugs although
several people did but that was part of
their code as well
so not the smartest criminals okay so
not the smartest criminals
meaning they're not trying to play the
oh i'm gonna beat the odds of seven
percent one person fourteen
so you're saying they're scared like if
you scare them they run away like a
little cat
is it are they are they scared criminals
like can you scare them away from the
industry or no
no not really okay so so this is all
they know
okay so business model to catch them
i'm just i'm not in your world but i'm
just thinking about it so
if it's super bowl and these are the
girls that are doing it you know they're
coming in and hey
customers go people gonna they're gonna
go online to get somebody hey i had one
too many drinks and they
call somebody how do i find somebody hey
we got so
it's the business model to go to the
super bowl
and go find those sites and call 100 200
400 of them then you send your guys to
go
meet with the girls and then you tell
the girls
that you're willing to help them out and
interrogate them to get a feel if they
are working with somebody
and then you have them come with you you
can't get all 300 of them because
they're scared for their lives that that
you know individuals it's the
relationship with the pimp and the
prostitute and
you know how that relation if it's
fear-based absolutely
then you convince a percentage to go
with you
and then you backtrack giving them
protection and safety
and then through backtracking you find
out who it is
and then you go track them down but at
that point they know that you've taken
some of their people so they're probably
on the run
is that part of the business model at
least not yours because you're not the
one that does that you just give intel
is that one part of the business model
that the law enforcement does or no
yeah so that's that's exactly what law
enforcement does uh law enforcement
you know gets in front of the girls uh
because you got it you gotta have a
witness
right you gotta you gotta have you gotta
have proof uh gets in front of them and
says hey
you know and usually a lot of times
using our intel here's what we know
about you
we know that you you and that girl over
there are actually all connected and we
know that you're run by this guy
we know that he's sitting in a car in
the parking lot um all we need you to do
is is
tell us that he's holding you against
your will and uh and we got this
or in many many cases what what can
happen
is uh you know the human trafficker is
controlling the girl
so he'll go drop her off at whatever
venue
and as as uh as he's dropping her off
law enforcement swoops in and uh and
catches them together
so so you you do have those types of
cases but some of these are very very
insidious
we had a case in the southwestern united
states with girls on her own
so we thought she was a human
trafficking victim we were sure she was
a human trafficking victim and our
analysts
are really really good yet when
the law enforcement wrapped her up she
was on her own well after questioning
her for about
20-30 minutes she broke down crying and
the human trafficker had her baby
and was threatening to hurt her baby and
had her baby in another city
and that was the handle he was using to
control her hands
makes sense what a way to hold somebody
hostage
um so
how much does the us government to to
fight what you guys are fighting you
can't do with a couple million dollars
how much is the u.s government putting
behind this like how much are they
saying we are going to fight human
trafficking we're going to put up this
much money
and then go and help certain
organizations to you know accelerate the
process of
eliminating if not as much as we can to
get rid of human trafficking
so the us government spends less
than a dollar per human trafficking
victim globally
globally which is globally it's a 20 to
40 million
people globally so you're telling me
it's only 20
to 40 million a year the the last
numbers we had
are that the us government spends 22
million dollars
a year fighting human trafficking like
specifically dedicated to fighting human
trafficking
so so so let me ask you why uh
so which which president has been the
most
is it because it's an uncomfortable
topic for presidents to campaign behind
that no one wants to talk about because
it's
you know it's a little bit of an
uncomfortable topic you know to talk
about human trafficking
why haven't presidents campaign behind
something like this
and made it an issue for people to say
yeah i think we need to put
i mean right now we just did 1.9
trillion dollars right okay
what's the big deal if you put 10
billion behind something like this this
is
actually emotionally painful to the
parents that lost their kid and they go
through this and
you know when someone goes through this
to get them back to living a normal life
and
rather than wanting to commit a suicide
the percentages are so high that
very rarely do you get them back to
being normal it's a very it's a big
fight that they have and it takes years
it doesn't take three six months and
many times it takes three four five
years
to get him back to saying okay this is
not your fault you didn't do this
it's okay you got to move on why
wouldn't the government want to fund
this and put some money behind it
that's a great question and i don't have
an answer for that
this is uh this is such a problem
uh and it kind of goes back to what i
said in the beginning like we have
whole government bureaucracies that
spend tens of billions of dollars to
fight
legal the the illicit sale of legal
commodities
yet we don't have a single government
agency that is focused on this
issue and why you know why
when i was at the cia did we have this
intelligence on a human trafficker in
another country
and was there nowhere to send it you
know why is
why is delta not being sent in
to go take down you know major human
traffickers overseas
yeah i mean these these are legitimate
questions we need to be asking of our
politicians and our policymakers to say
why is this not a priority
and and and human or
politicians do campaign on this issue
i mean if you if you look at it they
talk about it but but
show me the money if it's if you're
serious about it right the the
uh the bible says where your where's
your where your treasure lies
there your heart will be also uh so show
me
show me the money that we're actually
spending uh we've seen lots of bills
come through
saying that this much is gonna be spent
or that much is going to be spent but
they all go unfunded
so how how united are
all of you on the private side meaning
someone like you a tim ballard a you
know
there's there's men there's a good
amount of you that are you guys all
pretty united or is it a pretty
competitive environment or is it all
we're united because we're fighting the
same fight
it's united we're we're fighting the
same fight uh
you know what we do with deliver fun
we're the only organization in the world
that does what we do
and you know the the other folks out
there be it international justice
mission is a great example you know we
work
uh we work closely with some of their
folks they're the only group that does
what they do national center for missing
and exploited children is a phenomenal
organization right a lot of people don't
realize that actually is a
private non-profit that john walsh
started around the missing kids issue
they uh we work very closely with them
uh and so
so you you have all these various groups
that kind of do different pieces of it
you know one of the one of the key
components of the fight against human
trafficking
is the restoration homes you know these
are people who have
started their started non-profits to
provide restoration services
to uh to human trafficking victims uh
and so
so it does get into this environment
where
you know especially if you have people
with really really good hearts
but no business experience or no
business sense and they don't have the
right
business people wrapped around them i've
been incredibly
blessed in that i've had big business
brains
you know really come in and help us out
not only with money but
but to show us where the potholes in the
road are and so
on the restoration side you have a lot
of organizations that are just
trying to do the right thing to help
these victims but
they don't know how to do it in a
repeatable scalable way
so so so you and tim tim ballard have a
relationship like you guys do stuff
together
no no as i understand it they
predominantly
focus overseas okay um you're more
you're more domestic
and we are we are only domestic
domestic okay yes uh okay so
you know give us a um i mean
the where i was going with this was the
following where i was going with this is
how often have you guys gotten in front
of congress and made a case how often
have you guys gone to dc and made a case
how often do you guys
unite together and make a case how often
have you guys
gone and gotten celebrities behind
something like this to make a case how
often
uh have we you know rallied people if if
if uh save the world uh
save uh uh make it a better place to you
and
uh you know the song back in the days
you know which one i'm talking about
they don't want to get paid for they're
just like look we're doing it for a good
cause
and there are people that are willing to
do that who
who's who's leading that today i know i
know
uh ashton kutcher did some stuff and he
was pretty active and you can tell
the pain when he was speaking about it
so i do
i don't see this as a democrat
republican or independent
thing i just see this as a listen this
ain't politics this is kids
period and all you need to know to uh
uh emotionally be connected to this is
to have a kid or a younger sibling
as long as you have a kid or a younger
sibling and you emotionally experience
that you're like the
no-brainer i'll support it how can i
support it how come
no one's been able to get in front of
the government for the government to say
we're going to put a billion 2 billion 5
billion timber behind it
you know it's funny we were actually
coordinating with ashton kutcher and and
uh i was on a call with him and you know
he
he goes in front of congress um i was
asked to
speak in front of congress three times
and every time
two days before they canceled why is
that
um you know uh yoda soros at the
national center for missing exploited
children who's the chief legal counsel
there
she does you know she goes and talks to
policy makers on a routine basis but
national center for missing exploited
children
gets 60 million dollars a year from the
federal government so
maybe now and that's predominantly
focused around the missing kids issue
and that's not
human trafficking specific so so
children who go missing you know foster
kids like i was a foster kid right i got
lucky
um i very easily could have been uh
a human trafficking victim uh kids by
the way foster kid is 60
it's it's a very big number yeah um
missing kids
uh national center mis estimates that
once a child goes
goes missing or or runs away within the
first 48 hours they'll be
they'll be approached by a human
trafficker because these human
traffickers know where
to find them and they're and they're
cruising around looking for them so
there you are a
you know a runaway teen in in
seattle in the winter and you're sitting
on a park bench and people think that
you're just a homeless team
and if you ran away then i guess you are
a homeless teen at that point human
trafficker comes by with a warm car and
says hey you want some food
get in yeah so so then my next question
would be and i was on a flight one time
i think it was 14 years ago it was 0.607
i was on a flight one time
and me and my uh a friend were sitting
next to each other and
and she looks at the girl sitting in
front of us says pat
take a look at this it seems a little
weird and i said what do you mean i said
look you know every time i look at her
phrase she looks scared i'm trying to
talk to her
so she waited for the guy to go to the
bathroom
and the guy was probably 62 years old
and she was probably 12 13 years old she
looked like she had a little pouch like
almost being pregnant
and she started talking to her who is
that man sitting next to you how are you
sweetie you know
trying to kind of and she talks to her
and she's like
i can't talk to you and he's like is
this your daddy
i can't talk to you and and i'm
listening i'm like dude this
this girl is frightened on this flight
right
so so i follow the guy i'm not trying to
make a scene i follow my case i'm trying
to start a conversation with him
and i look at him i'm like yeah
something's wrong with you buddy there's
something very weird which i started hey
so tell me where you guys from you know
i'm just trying to start a conversation
and hey can you leave us alone i'm like
can you leave us alone who the hell says
can you leave a salon like
it's totally fine so is that your
daughter none of your business yes
that's my daughter i'm like
even if that's your daughter you're 62
okay fine we're living in america times
are changing maybe you're
sure so then i go up to the
flight attendant i said listen this this
is a little bit
42 years of me living i've never done
this in my life you know i'm convinced
this guy was a dirty guy and i wanted to
take it on my own but i had
you know friends i knew on the flight
i'm not trying to make a you know but at
the same time i said
you know do you guys have any agency
people on the flight i know typically on
every flight there's somebody that's an
agent you know that's on i don't need to
know the answer to the question
but there's a very weird situation going
on here there's this man sitting here
and this girl and
my friend and i started talking to them
and
she's scared for her life and
i feel like i have to do something about
this but i'm not an agent i don't do
anything
can you please tell your management so
she said let me see what i can do
so they come back they look start
talking to him
at this point he's thinking that i
because he looked at me like pissed off
even more
and i really at this point i'm not i'm
really don't care at this point what's
going on so
he goes back she goes back and tells the
other person so now everybody's kind of
trying to find out what's going on
and i said do you mind you know not
letting them get off the flight
and have some agents coming on board and
kind of doing what they're doing so sir
we have it from here
let us take care of it we make sure we
we want to reassure you we're going to
do something
i left i waited all i know is the guy
and the girl didn't get off
and they were kind of somebody was
talking to them i don't know what
happened there
but you know that was just my gut i may
have been wrong
never felt like that before ever in my
life i'm a pretty intuitive guy
i'm around a lot of people i travel very
regularly
and it it felt very very weird
what what can so there's two directions
i'm going with this on one is i'm
talking as a citizen
what can i do if i see something that's
wary
and something just doesn't look right
what what can
we do to
help because we got you know 350 million
people say 40 million people living in
america
human traffickers it's not a big number
say it's in the thousands
but we got a lot of other adults that
are out there looking all this other
stuff
what signs can we look for and what can
we do in that moment
you know to maybe potentially
help one girl that is going through the
mess that she's going with a trafficker
so the answer to that question actually
goes right back to the story you just
told
uh the you know people say well what
should we look for uh well people
will tell you that you know you look for
a girl with a crown
tattoo on her neck well that's that's
pretty old that's about
20 that that's about 20 years ago that
traffickers were doing what's that
problem what's the crime they they put a
crown they mark
their victims um they used to mark them
like on their neck or on their face
until they figured out that it's pretty
easy for law enforcement to figure out
so they stopped doing that they still do
mark them but usually in a place that
you can't see
and but when you see something that just
doesn't make sense right especially when
it when it involves fear
uh we all know what fear looks like i
mean we could see it in other people
it's a
survival instinct uh that allowed
you know mankind to proliferate say hey
you know i'm afraid because there's a
lion over there
so we all know what it looks like so
when you see that you did exactly the
right thing which is you want to tell
the next level of authority that you can
right so in this case it was
you know it was the the crew at the
airline
if if it's not the crew at the airline
it's going to be the
airport security it's going to be a law
enforcement officer
it's going to be calling your county
sheriff all of those things
but then you get this problem with too
much
data because that law enforcement
officer who's a human trafficking
detective
that's only one of their jobs they're
also
working traffic two days a week and
they're also doing something else
because law enforcement is undermanned
uh as much as anybody in the government
so that's where we come in
in that we provide technology software
so
it connects those cases across the
country so that those
those law enforcement officers can log
into our system and say all right
you know has any of the information that
this that
this girl gave me or this guy gave me
has anybody else in law enforcement seen
this before
and so they'll search it and oh yep sure
enough there's a guy
there's a detective in nebraska all
right let me call that detective in
nebraska and see
see what's going on right and so so
getting people to report things i mean
even if you don't
i mean you don't know it's a human
trafficking victim it could be
something completely different it could
be you know the
the girl's parents had died in a car
crash and this is an uncle she doesn't
know very well who was the last of kin
who now is taking
you know taking her on i mean you have
no idea but the point was that something
wasn't right and so
you told somebody and that is exactly
what the public needs to do
and err on the side of caution er right
just err on the side of caution like
this
could be a human trafficking problem it
could be
a kidnapping problem there was something
going on
so we need to tell somebody you know
again i'm not in your world but if i'm
in your world
you know i think speed is critical
right call to action is critical and
you know i understand the research data
all of that but that's to hunt down the
trafficker right but when you're in an
opportunistic moment
you know um
there has to be because once once
they're gone they're gone your
opportunity is gone
you know how much does speed
play a role in catching traffickers when
you see an opportunity to execute
immediately
meanwhile the law enforcement agencies
you're dealing with maybe that's not at
their top of their priority
so what happens when you event intel do
they execute immediately it's like oh we
can't do it today we're so busy we'll do
it tomorrow
how does the level of speed to call to
action
i'm gather the information i got it how
how fast does execution happen
executing the data that i got to go
catch this guy what have you noticed
yourself
not near fast enough uh law enforcement
always wants to execute on it
immediately but great example is at the
super bowl
uh we had over 700 intelligence packages
go out
uh during the super bowl operation i if
you took every single law enforcement
officer
in the tampa era area and solely
dedicated them to
the human trafficking problem they
wouldn't have been able to get to the
bottom of it and and that's a
that's a very harsh reality of how big
this problem is
and it's gotten this big because we
never we never
took combating it seriously so now
we're at the super bowl my analysts
they know many human traffickers who
showed up at the super bowl and then
left the super bowl with their girls
well quite frankly that sucks
but we have all that data
and now we know where they're going
because they're advertising so
we know where they're going to end up
the computers will let us know when they
settle
and then we can call law enforcement in
that area and say hey
these guys were just in the super bowl
and the reality is sometimes law
enforcement says hey we actually don't
have anybody who deals with human
trafficking
we don't want anything to do with that
um and
in which case you're like all right why
why do they say that though
because they're not funded for it all
right go to go to your local you i'm
sure you know some folks in law
enforcement
go to your police chief and say hey um
show me show me the budgets
for your your narcotics unit for your
gangs unit for your property crime unit
and for your
human trafficking unit and what you'll
find is that the gang's unit is fully
funded
narcotics unit is fully funded property
crime that touches commercial real
estate
uh which touches their donors the
mayor's donors so
guarantee you that's funded and many
times they'll tell you we actually don't
have a human trafficking unit
we have a detective who does something
else who
if a human trafficking case comes along
they go ahead and and they deal with it
so you you obviously the idea of
defunding the police just
even hurts us even more because you need
funding to be able to
execute on some of these things so uh a
question
question for you on on
how many total traffickers are they're
not victims but how many total
traffickers
if you can estimate are there in america
today
i would estimate it around the man it'd
be
hard 25 to 50 000 mark what
i'm sorry go ahead and and the way we
get that is again
we're talking illicit underground
commodities right elicit underground
networks
very very difficult to get good data on
that but the national center for missing
exploited children estimates that about
a hundred thousand
children a year children
enter the human trafficking market in
america
in america and these are american these
are american citizens this is not
lethal weapon and there's you know
chinese coming in over
shipping containers or the movie taken
um right this is this is uh this is
our sons and daughters that are being
targeted
primarily on internet platforms uh
social media
uh gaming consoles by human traffickers
and groomed which is what they call it
into their
into their business enterprise how many
total victims if it's 25 to 50
traffickers how many victims total
so we we don't know we know that about a
hundred thousand children a year
enter the cycle we know that the average
life of a human trafficking victim is
seven years
so you can do some you can do some
fox and rabbit uh economics on that
pretty quick
to figure out that it it's it's hundreds
of thousands of human trafficking
victims
if you do 700 if you do 700 if that 100
000 stays but the next year the 100
000 stays for seven years and the next
year so out of a
seven year period you're at 700 000 but
they're rolling up so it's about 1.4
1.23
million okay what is the worst example
we've made of human traffickers
the worst example yeah meaning
what what is the crime of a human
trafficker and
what how have we publicly um
you know made an example of them to
punish them in a way where others sit
there and say
do you hear about what happened to
johnny yeah i don't know man they're
cracking down very quickly they just got
another one and another one and another
one and another one
how do we advertise the human
traffickers are getting caught and how
bad of a punishment are we passing down
to them so others are kind of being a
little bit more
hesitant about what they're doing so the
minimum mandatory sentence for
human trafficking at the federal level
is 15 years
that's it that's the minimum or maximum
no that's the minimum mandatory sentence
we see human traffickers get 15 years
they'll get
they'll get house arrest for the first
two or three years while their cases
is going through uh that will come off
their sentence and then we've seen human
traffickers get probation after as
little as five years
i mean think about it you can get 30
years for money laundering
why is it that on a federal charge you
can get
more years in prison for money
laundering than you can for human
trafficking
now in some states like texas and
montana
i mean it's it you actually want to get
a state charge because it's
life in prison for a human trafficking
charge
so what we're seeing and i actually
believe that this is the right
this is the right answer we're seeing
the states
start to take this this this issue into
their own hands
um with some supplemental funding by the
federal government
and they're starting to push that
forward one of the best human
trafficking task forces
in the united states is the hetra in in
houston it's the human trafficking
rescue alliance uh
it's it's uh multiple jurisdictions
dozens of jurisdictions in the
in the houston area um and it's it's a
very much a
local human trafficking task force the
feds have some involvement in it for
sure
but you're looking at about a ten to one
local agent to federal
agent ratio on fighting human
trafficking
and by the way their full-time human
trafficking analyst
is actually one of my employees because
they
they couldn't afford to hire a full-time
human trafficking analyst so
we uh we got a guy who came from uh
the the human intelligence operations
side of seal team six
and hired him on a full-time salary and
what he does is he hunts down
human traffickers on the intel side for
those law enforcement officers
but notice i said that one human
trafficking task force
la's got a decent one new york has a
decent one
chicago's is up and coming uh
but 80 of america is rural
and the human traffickers know that
moving through rural america
is the best way not to get caught nick
what what do you think is appropriate
punishment for human trafficking
i think life in prison sounds pretty
good to me nothing above that life is
plenty is what you're thinking
uh yeah i think i think life is uh i
think life is pretty good um you know
beyond
that you start getting into uh political
issues
that um you may you made a video on this
uh that i thought was
was very good for a guy in my situation
um
in talking about you know various
political issues so let's just start
with
let's just start with life in prison
let's get that locked in
uh right we know that that worked when
we
when we had gangs uh targeting
law enforcement officers and we made you
know the killing of a law enforcement
officer
uh a life sentence we know that that
worked
so let's try that for human trafficking
and then and then let's see where that
data takes us and
move beyond that top states i looked at
for human trafficking i saw california
texas florida nevada vegas specifically
obviously vegas makes uh some sense
but then they said the epicenter is new
york city
what would you say having been in this
industry yourself where do you see
a lot of the human trafficking taking
place
so human trafficking is transitory uh
right the
the traffickers i mean at the end of the
day let's remember they are they are
business people and i don't want to say
business men because a lot of human
traffickers are women
um so they are they're business people
who are going to go where the market
opportunity is
so new york city is not a problem right
now because people have been fleeing
new york city because of tax issues and
and covet
and so you're starting to see an uptick
in human trafficking activity in places
like texas where
you know montana uh rural america where
people where people are flooding to
and human traffickers can't get hotel
rooms um
they can't you know if there's a big
coveted lockdown so they're going to go
to the places where there isn't
a coved lockdown then they follow the
market
god okay so they're not as dumb as you
think they are
a little bit smart yeah but how smart do
you have to be to say hey i'm not making
any money in this city let's try the
next one
um you know it's they're they're looking
at it as
as a uh let's say great examples um
consumer electronics show right it's a
market opportunity for them you've got
all kinds of people from all over the
world come to las vegas to
you know to to party and they want girls
at those parties and and they want to
they want to show up so they'll have
human traffickers who will
who will leave nebraska to go to nevada
to sell their girls in nevada because
that's an opportunity for them
they'll sell them along the way they
might hit a couple other cities on their
way back home
so so um
when you're saying some of these human
traffickers are not men they're women
epstein maxwell jalane jalene you would
put as a human trafficker would she
categorically be a human trafficker it's
just a high-end human trafficker right
from what i know of the case yes i'm not
an expert on that case by any means but
but from what i know yes um you that's
that's the
the misconception is that all human
traffickers are men and that is not the
case
uh i mean many many human traffickers
are women
many of them became human trafficking
victims
and then the stockholm syndrome set in
pretty bad and they started
they started essentially acting as a
business manager for their human
trafficker
to get preferential treatment uh right
preferential uh
uh you know maybe maybe some freedoms
things like that and then eventually
maybe the human trafficker goes to
prison and they just take over the
business enterprise
interesting um last question and then
i'll wrap up with
the you know one last short this is the
next topic and then the last one i'll
wrap up with a basic question
uh parents um what what
what can we as parents do to um
be alert be aware anticipate
prevent what can we do to be smarter
with this
be nosy and be in your children's lives
know who they're talking to know what's
no no know what's going on know whether
or not that game that they're playing
has a chat feature and
and i talked to parents like well i'm
just not good with technology when it's
time to get good with technology
because if you're going to allow your
children
to if you're going to allow your
children to to use a gaming console or
to use a phone
um look at look at that as a weapon
right
no parent would hand their child a
loaded gun and say oh
well i'm just not good with guns so i
don't i don't know how to check to see
if it's loaded
tell me how a gaming console or a phone
is any different
um right our our job as parents
is to protect our children and that
means
protecting them from things that that
they don't understand the consequences
for
if you go to our website at
deliverfund.org
you will see a you'll see a video
of a boy who was
uh trafficked he was uh he was groomed
through a gaming console
um our legal counsel says i can't say
which one
um but he was he was uh he was groomed
through a a
uh a very recognizable gaming console
one of the top three
uh and the and he thought he was talking
to another
boy his age in another state and then
that human trafficker
when you know got him to tell him over a
period of months where he lived
human trafficker then um contacted him
and said hey
um i'm with my dad up the street why
don't you uh why don't you come out and
say hi
and so the boy did jumped in the car
obviously it was a it was a grown man
took his phone they found the phone in
the the front yard of a neighbor's house
and took this young boy to another state
now luckily one of our analysts kara
smith you can find her on on instagram
at kara the huntress um which is kind of
our little name for her because all she
she lives to hunt down human traffickers
and she's a former nsa analyst
she was able to find this this young boy
where he
was and uh within a couple of hours
and law enforcement kicked in the door
of this guy's house and rescued the boy
uh within 48 hours but but that that's a
great example and and
the father of this young boy uh
he was an i.t security specialist at a
very
large no at a very large i.t security
company so
he had all the right filters on his on
his router
he had all the right stuff he was doing
the right things
he just assumed that because he pushed
the easy button
for for you know keeping keeping the you
know pornography and stuff like that
out of office home internet um that
there was no other way
that these human traffickers could get
these children so you see your kids
talking to somebody on a on a game
on a gaming console or or on a phone you
know hey who are you talking to
what are they saying do you really know
that's them
you know helping children understand
that the person on the other side of the
internet
could be anybody it could be who they
who they claim to be
and it also could not you know my my uh
my other company verify you know we we
do all this work around
fraud for investments and uh and
it shocks me how many very
very very bright very wealthy
individuals who have
made billions of dollars end up being
defrauded
by somebody just because they took their
word for it next thing you know they're
losing tens of millions of dollars
so if that can happen to uh that can
happen to private equity firms
if that can happen to investment banks
if that can happen to uh you know
venture capital firms
it surely can happen to a teenage kid
who's playing a video game
you're crazy when you're just thinking
about like how they go about
by the way do you know jarrah uh
hutchins or no
can't say i do no error hutchins and
dallas you don't okay
she uh she's one of those that loves
fighting human trafficking and she
teaches people how to get uh licensed to
carry and she's she's phenomenal she's
awesome phenomenal what she does yeah i
watched a movie
years ago i know you're not a movie guy
you're a music guy but you're not a
movie guy you haven't even seen the
movie jack ryan and that jack ryan
no i haven't so i watched this movie
called disconnect
and disconnect was a great movie to show
how a kid gets bullied online
and this this guy's um father
parents go through a divorce you know
he's just not he's just not connected
you know he's just so busy i don't have
any time i don't have any time he's
actually they're not divorced one the
other kid is parents divorced
so this the kids the bullies in school
find out that this kid
likes this girl so they make a fake
profile and send a picture of somebody
else's naked picture without the face on
and said i'll show you mine if you show
me yours
so she's they the guy send a picture
of another girl online that they got so
he then sends a picture of himself
naked the boys end up using a picture
against him share it with everybody in
school because they're you know kids
they do stupid things
obviously that's cyber bullying this kid
is so embarrassed to go to school
that he ends up hanging himself and his
sister walks in on time where he doesn't
kill himself
but that has nothing to do with human
trafficking but it does
oh it does it absolutely does the first
two three steps
where i'll show you mine if you show me
yours i recommend every parent to watch
this movie because it's a
very interesting movie and a guy that's
in this movie is the guy from horrible
bosses i don't know what the guy's name
is jason is it jason bateman jason
uh is that is that an actress i don't i
think that's the actor's name jason
jason bateman who's in he's done a great
job but uh
you know i think i think there needs to
be more education on this i saw the
hotline you know there's a hotline for
human trafficking and and is that
something you support with what they do
is that an organization that you support
so the national human trafficking
hotline is uh is a good uh
it's a good resource but it's the best
resource
is to call your local law enforcement uh
because that's where it's actually
happening right national human
trafficking hotline is a hotline in dc
um you know doing the best they can from
there but
you want to call where it's actually
happening because like you said patrick
it
is speed right time is of the essence
in these cases so you want to get that
law enforcement officer
on the ground where you see the problem
involved
and and what you brought up is is what
uh what is referred to as sextortion
human traffickers use that they they
create a profile
some girl thinks that she's talking to
some good looking guy who's a couple
years older they get a picture
and then they use that to control these
to control these girls we've actually
had cases
where there were teenage girls who were
living at home with their
parents who were being trafficked after
school when their parents thought that
they were at soccer practice
and all they knew was that something was
not right with their daughters
but their daughter wouldn't talk about
it because this trafficker was
threatening to
you know show their church or show their
parents
or something like that so helping your
children understand that one
you can kind of survive anything right i
mean yes
if if that naked picture of you gets
gets put on the internet
um well one if you're underage those
platforms have a responsibility to take
that to take that down and there's legal
consequences if they don't
so that's the first thing the second
thing is
what will happen to you if you if you
cooperate with a human trafficker
is far worse than anything that that
could ever happen
uh otherwise and and the last piece
is for children to understand
that anything they put on the internet
lives
forever right unless you get as lucky as
me and you have a government agency just
to go start scrubbing things off
right i mean i'm one of the few people
who in their mid-30s had got a
got a fresh fresh start on the internet
um that just doesn't happen
so for children to understand that if
you take a picture on a phone it lives
forever
if you send it it lives forever
and event you have to assume that
anything you do on the internet
is going to end up on the front page of
the washington post
you know it's funny i i've never said
this ever in an interview i hope this
video gets millions of views
if anybody's watching you if you know i
mean if any of you i've never said i
hope this video gets millions of views
i hope this envy gets millions of views
and i hope people share it with other
parents
and give the thumbs up everything that
the algorithms work in favor of you to
putting this all over the place because
people need to get
educated uh just in the last hour and 15
minutes however long we've been going
minus the conversation and i had
offline i've gotten smarter and i i
appreciate your time i appreciate
everything you uh shared with us and
uh we will leave the link below to both
of your companies obviously the deliver
being at the top
and we'll put the other one as well and
um how people can find you
they can find it easily through your
website right is that is that the best
way to find you through your website
yeah you find me through the website um
i'm on all the social media platforms uh
at deliver fund nick and uh linkedin is
the one that i'm the most
active on uh and thank you patrick for
for helping us
shine a light on this issue i mean this
is it's a team effort
and everyone's got a got a part to play
and and so thank you for that
i think you play a very important role
and i hope more people get inspired to
do what you do once they leave the
military
because we need the people like you and
i hope
any government officials or anybody
that's involved in politics who watches
this content
also has the courage to bring it up to
folks in power
who see value in this so eventually the
budget for this goes into the billions i
think 10 20 30 billion to eliminate this
at least in america and then eventually
gradually work internationally once
again thank you thank you for your time
and uh a very very very good very good
interview with you the last hour and a
half i really enjoyed it
my brain is going a million miles an
hour thanks again nick thank you patrick
i've not asked you this before but i'm
asking you right now and hopefully you
will do this as a valuetainer please
share this video text it to people hit
the thumbs up button
share it whatever way you can for other
people to see it for the algorithms to
be on our favor because this is not a
message about how you make millions how
you make billions how you become
successful
it's not entertainment this is purely
something that's about education and
awareness i'm asking you
share it with any parent that you know
and say just watch this video
get a paper and pen out you're going to
want to pay attention to this one here
and having said that if you enjoy this
interview you learn from it
i have a real life story of somebody
that experienced this her name is janome
park if you've never seen that interview
click over here to watch that
and uh hopefully together we can create
more awareness of this and even if we
make this much of a dent
and this leads to helping out 20 kids
100 kids 5 000 kids 100 000 kids
we did our job take care everybody bye